I am Noah and I
[Music]
this is your at-home bootcamp workout so
we're gonna do a course centric AB
centric workout today that's really
going to make those those ABS pop give
you that washboard look so let's get it
right now we're going to go for a sit-up
with a flip in proper sit-up position
you can bring our feet together if we
want you're going to make sure that chin
doesn't drop to your chest you're going
to give me a full sit-up hit it right
here right hand goes behind your body
and he is going to come right to that
elbow or higher then bring it right back
down switch sides so until you get the
form we talked about this until you get
the form don't you can go as slow as you
want ok sit up hand comes down you're
thinking about it right now then as you
start to get the form you're going to
hit it a little bit faster because come
the move doesn't matter if you do it
quickly sure if your form shoddy then
we're going to take it right here we're
going to go into plank position
right here we're going to do a kick
throat so we're going to let our body
lie on that one arm like a pillar okay
keep it nice and tight then watch this
we're going to bring it back down into a
plank ten times to ten times - okay
actually ten times then we're going to
burn it out there's a couple ways to do
this there's an advanced way okay and
then there's a spider-man pushup so or
lower impact kind of lower intensity
we're going to hold a plank position
either on our hands standing plank or on
our elbow plank and we're going to hit
those obliques with a glute raise to an
oblique drive we bring our knee right to
that shoulder okay we're going to repeat
one on each side that'll be the last
minute okay so to recap we do the setup
with the flip each side alternating one
minute we're going to take it down into
our next move which is the kick through
one kick through side and ten open shots
with the plank plank jumping our feet
open shot so right here ten times then
right back one
- okay gotcha
that's a second minute third minute
we're going to take it down into that
spider-man push-up alternating
squeezing your obliques as we bring that
knee up as high to our shorter as we can
okay now you can't the modification hold
that elbow if you can't hit it with a
push-up gotcha
so for slow as you need same thing with
the with the next one you can take this
one nice and slow try to get a little
bit deeper into that squeeze as you get
more comfortable if you could only hit
it there that's fine okay take it nice
and slow but as you start to get
accustomed to the move touch it got it
so one minute on the clock knee comes
right up there you go where you feeling
the scene all over the place over the
place
let's try to keep that foot down so take
it even slower ok sit up first part 1
put that hand down part to flip over
part 3 now right back to where you saw
it so once it up hand comes down down
that's it and it's like I said you
didn't just wake up knowing this move
you have to learn this move so sit there
slow repetitions until you can start
picking up the pace so take a little
breather right here while I keep you on
that
we're going to go for that kick through
so you're going to kick that hand on to
try to keep it nice and in alignment
keeping your abs nice and tight so
you're strong through that on to her
sure to drop down on our shoulder keep
everything tight 1 2 then back to plank
for those 1000 shots go right back 1 to
10 they're perfect
so like I said take it as slow as you
need to until you get the form and time
now what we're going to do is we're
going to take this right down then oh
sure oh are you fancy you are so fancy
right now that's like first time at bat
home run perfect keeping those ABS nice
meeting with your chest your hips aren't
dipping down that floor and that's it
alright so to recap guys we started this
absent Rick core workout with one minute
of sit up flips we then went into one
minute of the kick through with the 10
open shuts between each one of those
finish off with a minute of the
spiderman push-ups it's really good one
I like that one make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any other
fighting weight episodes
[Music]
you